hello my name is sarah dickerson
i'm a scientist at horizon discovery and
i will be presenting this poster on
crispr a using synthetic guide rna
so synthetic guide rna is beneficial in
many respects
for example it allows for short-term
expression and enables you to avoid
cloning which are some of the challenges
associated with using express guide rnas
crispr can be repurposed from a gene
editing tool to a transcriptional
regulation system
a nucleus deficient mutant of cas9 known
as dkas9
does not cleave the dna but retains the
ability to bind
guide rnas and localize to the target
dna
when dcas9 is fused to a transcriptional
regulator
it can activate transcription commonly
referred to as
crispr a several crispr a systems have
been developed
including suntag sam and vpr which we
show here
initially researchers used express
signal guide rnas for crisp array
and in data not shown we have found that
the synthetic two-part crispr rna and
tracer rna system
can also be used to activate
transcription with crispr a systems
here we investigate the use of a five
prime and modification of the crispr rna
and the three prime end modification of
the tracer rna in performing crispr
a we wanted to see if these
modifications would have an effect
on activation so we compared modified
crispr rna tracer rna
which is shown in dark green to
unmodified shown in light green
for four different genes and then
measure transcriptional activation
via r2 qpcr here we show
transcriptional fold activation for an
individual crispr rnas as well as the
pools of four
modifications allow for a dramatic
increase in activation
additionally the pull of four crispr
rnas also greatly enhance
activation for example there is a more
than
30-fold increase in activation of titan
with modified crispr rnas pooled
compared to unmodified crispr rnase
to determine how synthetic guide rna is
compared to
express single guide rna and lentiviral
expression
we compare the three methods for four
gene targets and report that synthetic
crispr rna trace rna result in gene
activation comparable to expressed
single guide rna
synthetic crispr rna and trace rna can
also be used with the sam system
sam is unique in that it uses a scaffold
tracer rna with an ms2 aptamer sequence
that recruits transcriptional activators
we found that the transcriptional
activation using either the sam or the
vpr system for six genes was comparable
there was no consistent trend across all
genes for example
transcriptional activation by sam was
higher for titan
whereas transcriptional activation for
vpr was higher for
l1 receptor 2. while most of the work
presented here
involves u2os cells stably expressing
dcas9 and their respective activators
we also demonstrate the effectiveness in
using synthetic
guide rnas with dcas9 vpr
mrna furthermore the advantage to using
either pure myosin dcas9vpr mrna or
egfp dcas9vpr mrna
is that it allows for enrichment
it is important to note that the basal
expression level of the target gene
may impact the level of activation
achievable
the bar graph represents transcriptional
activation ranked highest to lowest
for 23 different genes the endogenous
gene expression for each gene target
obtained from
rna-seq data is shown on the right
y-axis
we consistently found that genes that
have very low endogenous expression
levels
are typically activated to a higher
degree
for instance endogenous expression of l1
receptor 2
is very low so we are able to achieve a
dramatic increase
in activation with crispr a
synthetic guide rnas are also effective
for multiplexing
in which more than one gene may be
activated we demonstrate
that the level of transcriptional
activation achieved is similar
whether a single gene two genes or three
genes are simultaneously activated
synthetic crispr a crispr rna tracer rna
also enables pulled screening in an
arrayed format
as shown here using a cell line stably
expressing dcas9vpr
allows for fast and effective screening
u2sl stably expressing dcas9vpr
were transfected with the crispr a
library
consisting of 153 cytokine receptor
targets
where each well contained a pool of four
crisprna tracer rnas targeting one gene
also secretion was monitored by elisa
and then we were able to identify
al-6 regulators and here we identify
positive regulators of all six in red
and
negative regulators shown here in blue
so the work presented here shows that
synthetic guide rna can be successfully
used with crispr a systems like vpr
and sam multiple crispr rnas targeting
the same gene can be pulled to achieve
higher transcriptional activation of the
target gene
we also demonstrate that synthetic
crispr rna tracer rna
is ideal for simultaneous activation of
multiple genes
and is effective when used with
mrna and finally we showed that
synthetic guide rna can be used
for high throughput arrayed screening
applications
thank you for listening and please feel
free to reach out if you have any
questions
you